non non non tu ne peux pas faire ça Donald tu
ne peux pas faire ça en France ils allaient te
facturer tu sais cette histoire on
va nous facturer 25% ce sont des
entreprises américaines si elles font des affaires en France
j'ai dit non tu ne l'es pas'  Je ne vais pas
faire ça, je l'ai donné à mes gens deux
mois plus tard, ils ont dit qu'ils ne pouvaient pas
conclure un accord, j'ai dit que je ferai un accord, j'ai
appelé le chef de la France, vous connaissez
Mcon, vous connaissez Macron, c'est un très gentil
mec
macron et euh vraiment un ni un gars très sympa
j'ai dit Emmanuel comment vas-tu il a dit
bien j'ai dit j'ai entendu dire que tu allais
facturer 25% aux entreprises américaines pour faire
des choses au Mexique qui d'autre tu fais bien
personne encore mais nous le ferons  autre j'ai dit
non non mais tu ne vas pas le faire
Emanuel tu ne vas pas le faire non non Donald
c'est déjà passé j'ai dit bien tu ferais
mieux de le dépasser parce que si tu ne
le dépasses pas tu vas payer un  Tarif de 100%
sur tous les vins et champagnes
expédiés aux États-Unis
à partir de
ce soir non non non tu ne peux pas faire ça
Donald tu ne peux pas faire ça J'ai dit que je pouvais le faire
en fait je suis en train de le signer
maintenant non non non je d'accord  Ne regarde pas bien,
je ne vais pas le faire, nous n'allons pas le
faire, c'était la fin, Mike, c'était
la fin de
[Musique]